I don't have a problem with essential
oils and despite me making a video on
questions for pseudoscience about
essential oils I actually own a vial of
clove oil for when I have canker sores
and to be honest they're not that big of
a deal sure the homeopathic culture is a
little weird and the mid-level marketing
companies are questionable but as a
scientist it's nothing I'm too concerned
about besides most of the things people
use essential oils for are benign like
using it as an aroma to relax or adding
it to food or for general cleaning
purposes even if you use it for mild
ailments like muscle aches or
indigestion it's okay and there's
actually some evidence to back this up
generally speaking essential oils are
alright what's not alright is this
section of the graph right here medical
uses it's one thing to treat muscle
aches or an upset stomach but when
you're treating serious health
conditions like autoimmune disorders
ADHD fungal infections cancer diabetes
and antibiotics that's where essential
oils aren't okay now I just want to
preface that I'm not saying essential
oils aren't useful medicine because
they're essential oils or are sourced
from plants quite the contrary
a fair amount of life-saving medicine
has come from plants so to say that
something isn't medicinal because its
source seems unlikely to be useful is
not a valid argument instead an
experienced scientist rejects the
efficacy of a substance when there is a
lack of legitimate evidence there's
ideas floating around the internet and
some homeopathic groups that essential
oils cure cancer and many other absurd
claims because some wellness
professionals or laymen are the ones
making the absurd claims and they're not
just saying it they're using actual
scientific evidence to solidify their
points however unlike the robust and
brilliant experiments that gave us the
cure for polio and perfected organ
transplants these studies are more akin
to begging two rocks together to see
what sticks but where do these studies
come from and why aren't they valid well
a little background first when a drug is
being developed it goes through numerous
phases of testing first starting with
the discovery phase where scientists
find candidate drugs for a disease or
condition from there they perform
mechanism studies to understand how it
works once
the general workings of the drug is
understood it moves to clinical trials
where it's tested on humans in the early
phases of testing prior to being tested
on humans the drug is tested in vitro
which is testing the drug or substance
outside the body usually in a petri dish
or a test tube in vitro studies are used
because they're fast cheap and can be
easily quantified if the drug has
promising results it's put through more
robust testing on animals and then
humans from here the FDA approves or
denies it
it's these quick cheap in vitro studies
that essential oil retailers use as
proof of their medicinal properties now
as an ignorant layman you might say but
the in vitro tests show that the drug
worked so that's why I went on to
clinical trials wrong actually the drug
showed promising results was tested on
humans and was then proven to work with
positive results preclinical trials hold
no water in terms of actually working
you need human trials to prove that
besides cell culture tests tend to have
low tolerances to anything that's tested
on them and don't equate to testing in
the human body in fact there's a lot of
things you could place in a petri dish
and call it anti-cancer you could argue
gasoline is an antibiotic against mersa
all right guys here's my test on
gasoline effects against MRSA as you can
see here I have my petri dish full of
agar which has immersive bacteria in it
and we're just going to grab some
gasoline and just pour it on top
alrighty
this is to see if gasoline kills mersa
so as you can see there is no more versa
going on this petri dish so it's
concluded that gasoline kills mersa so
you can take gasoline now if you have
this terrible infection using in vitro
studies to prove essential oils our
medicine is like building a foundation
of a house and then saying you built an
entire house one wellness professional
who's notorious for this is this guy yet
look here medicine murders Rory's dr.
Josh axe or Travis Stork life is a
trained chiropractor in a doctor in
naturopathic medicine and unlike Travis
Stork is not a medical doctor there we
are
he promotes and sells homeopathic
remedies ranging from food supplements
to hygiene products one of his most
popular products is essential oils which
he claims does some pretty extraordinary
things I was reading an a study where
they found they were comparing different
herbs and oils and they found oregano to
be the strongest in terms of its some of
its antifungal properties so so powerful
at treating infections so oregano is
powerful at fighting off all forms of
pathogens
you know myrrh oil which has been shown
to cause apoptosis of cells so it's
actually programming cell death of
cancer cells
now something unique about oregano is
not only as an antibacterial it's also
antifungal anti-parasitic it fights off
yeast as well if you've got Candida you
absolutely need to be inhaling and
consuming clove in a regular - a number
of things but one of the biggest
benefits of cinnamon is it actually
helps in killing off dangerous microbes
now listen there's a story in the Bible
they did when this whole camp was sick
with a plague they actually fumigated it
with cinnamon oil and it said it killed
off the plague and strengthened the
kidneys in Chinese medicine it's done to
help strengthen the kidney chi and
overall energy Josh backs up his claims
with the litany of scientific studies
and to a regular person this would be
enough evidence that and the unique
thing here is that it's actually been
shown to fight off mersa however these
are not robust scientific studies
involving human trials but rather
how low in vitro studies performed on
simple cell and tissue cultures in fact
let's check one out right now so potent
antioxidant
okay so anti-cancer benefits so a lab
based study found that myrrh also has
potential anti-cancer benefits now this
here is a red flag a lab based study so
this is not tested so this this myrrh
was not tested on a person with cancer
or unlike like a tumor this is just if
you read through this is just on cancer
cells and in vitro studies so this does
not prove that myrrh is anti cancer in
granted they did say it's potential
anti-cancer benefits and they're not
saying yeah it's proven to kill cancer
but that's still I mean if you're like
an average Joe and you go onto this page
or like oh there's ten proven murder
benefits okay let's do we have your
potent antioxidant that's proven okay
and we have anti-cancer but like you're
not going to read through this little
blurb here and you're definitely not
gonna read through the study and the
study you know human cancer cells they
tested it on us on a cell culture you
know and so basically all they did was
as they as they took it was it was kind
of classical cancer and they grew the
culture and then they exposed it to more
oil and the more oil managed to kill or
reduce the cancer population in the in
the petri dish and it's like well hey it
killed the cancer it has anti-cancer
benefits but that's not a big
accomplishment a lot of things like I
said before will kill a culture of
cancer cells you know salt water will
kill cancer cells killing cancer cells
in an isolated environment is again you
can do that with like sunlight you know
but to kill cancer cells in the human
body where they're where they're growing
and they're hard to reach and they're
spreading that's much different than
just having a static you know a little
little colony it's like I kill the
cancer cells well like you
Danah mule them Wow my foot is now an
anti-cancer so that's kind of bad
antibacterial and antifungal benefits
historically myrrh was used to treat
wounds and prevent infections this is
true kind of light from ancient Israel a
couple thousand years ago but I mean at
least it's you know a little history
lesson there - it can still be used in
this manner on minor fungal irritations
such as athlete's foot bad breath so it
can still be used in this manner on
minor fungal irritation such as
athlete's foot and bad breath and etc
etc see what these studies says then so
they're saying it can be used on
athlete's foot like an actual human
infection only the study isn't tested on
a human with a fungal infection it's
tested on a disc diffusion assay so
again they took a culture of fungus
Aspergillus exposed it to a more oil you
know concentration or whatever some kind
of way they exposed it to it and it
killed the fungus woohoo I mean again
that's that's not a big accomplishment a
lot of things will kill any any kind of
culture in a petri dish
now what's hard about killing fungus is
that antibiotics will target bacteria
and they won't target the host
whereas fungus are eukaryotes as our
humans so it's very hard to find
remedies that will kill the fungus and
you know I mean all they had to do was
just find a study where they tested more
oil on a person with a fungal infection
and they could have said hey yeah but
instead they did this and my thought is
it is the eater couldn't find a study or
there were studies that use more oil and
it didn't it wasn't effective so this is
also a red flag that's very bad okay
Murrell can help fight certain types of
bacteria for example it seems and lab
studies to be potent against staph
infections interesting hmm
well first off it seems so they're not
even like yeah it's proven it's like it
seems so that's you know again if you're
just like the average person going
through this you're not gonna read this
whole blurb and be like HM well it seems
so I guess it's not you know clinically
proven it seems in lab studies to be
potent against staph infections so this
here is a problem they're saying that
more oil is effective in reducing or
treating staph infections but the study
that they have here is not on a case
where they treated a person with staph
infection instead what they did was they
took more oil and they took you know a
staph colony and they treated the colony
with more oil and it inhibited okay and
inhibited the biofilm for the biofilm
formation meaning you know it reduced
the growth or like the spreading of the
staph bacteria that is not the same as
saying it is a potent is potent against
staph infections if they have said it
seems in lab studies that it kills back
this to kill staph cultures you know in
a petri dish like yeah five stars that's
perfect but they didn't and then it's
funny too is they then I think they
injected or whatever but they they
exposed a nematode to the staph bacteria
and they treated it with more oil and it
reduced the virulence in the nematode
but the problem is like this is a
nematode it's not it's not even like a
lab rat even like remotely close to like
you know a mammal it's of nematode so
it's like why would you even bother you
know and so you know this is this like
adding insult to injury it's like yeah
we we tested it on like a culture and
then we test it on like a nematode
potent again staph infection and uh
staph infection in anemic
not a person or a rat or like a rabbit
or whatever so this is just really bad
this is a hot mess so these are the kind
of things you have to watch out for when
you're buying from essential oil people
like not dr. Josh axe to say that these
oils have proven anti-cancer or
antibiotic properties is taking one
massive leap of faith as well as being
grossly irresponsible as someone who has
experience in submitting products to the
FDA if you were to submit a drug with
this kind of evidence they'd laugh in
your face and then promptly kick you out
here's an interesting fact drugs that
proved successful in the early phases of
development and eventually move on to
clinical trials only about 10% actually
get approved by the FDA oh yeah but
you're more oil is definitely
anti-cancer yeah good job and frankly
it's not just Josh axe who's guilty of
this other much larger essential oil
firms use the same manipulation to
bolster their products which I'll be
covering more in depth in a future video
in conclusion essential oils marketed
towards benign treatments like sleep
aids indigestion or even improving
memory are at the consumers discretion
and don't really have any major negative
effects marketing essential oils to
treat serious conditions including
cancer is a no-no on the stupid scale
I'm reading essential oils at a seven
out of ten and on the harmful scale at a
four out of ten rubbish